[Music]
the hell is he doing rim of the world is
a tight collection of unincorporated
towns around the resort of Lake
Arrowhead in the San Bernardino
Mountains of California the area's
13,000 or so permanent residents form a
tight-knit community where many people
have grown up together and know each
other by name now I'm Carol Kephart
Ellen's mother
I'm Jackie apart the people are are
basically mountain people they will
support anything that's right reported
crime numbers are among the lowest in
California and respect for law
enforcement has always been high that
all changed on May 10th 2011 and 43 year
old Alan Kephart one of the community's
most beloved residents and a man with no
police record was inexplicably killed in
an altercation with San Bernardino
deputies during a traffic stop
Kephart's parents never thought this
could happen to someone like their son
that was the last thought by mine
because he was such an awesome person he
would never I never seen him bridges and
to anybody I never really ever seen him
raise his voice to anybody in 43 years
Alan Kephart lived on the mountain from
the time he was six years old he
graduated from the local high school
worked as an audio-visual technician and
volunteered his services for a radio
station and for his church at the time
of his death he was living with his
parents that's where he grew up that's
where his friends work he loved this
mountain this shouldn't happen to any
family and I'm even more saddened by the
cause and who caused it
on the afternoon of May 10th the
sheriff's deputy attempted to stop
Kephart for allegedly failing to yield
at a stop sign the Sheriff's Department
says that Kephart then failed to pull
over along this mountain road for a
short distance after less than a mile
Kephart pulled into the parking lot of a
Valero gas station what happened next
was captured by a security camera at a
nearby storage facility
Manuel Lujan was a witness at the scene
what we saw was him take him out throw
him to the ground and his face hit the
asphalt because he was his face was
bloodied what I think he was trying to
do was get back up over to his back you
know so he wouldn't be on his face
that's when the officer got up backed up
and tasered him and at that point that
was the other one that came down Bear
Springs Road came and also goes taser
out tasting the Sheriff's Department
will not reveal how many times Kephart
was tasered but five used taser
cartridges were entered into evidence
displayed still there then they checked
his vital signs and found out that
something wasn't right records at
Mountain Community Hospital indicate
Kephart's face was bloody and his skin
appeared modeled the skin around his
shoulders was broken by taser probes I
didn't see anything
that he did that would result in what he
got a lot of people filming it with
cameras and the scene the Sheriff's
Department
I seen him walking around taking cameras
from people they were filming it I'm not
sure I don't know if they deleted what
they were filming or what they did but
they were taking cameras Lujan joined
about a hundred and fifty locals at a
town hall meeting two weeks after the
incident where the people of the
mountain didn't hold back and describing
their own experiences with local law
enforcement I'm afraid
I'm more afraid of the cops up here than
I am down here we are the small mountain
community if we have to take the abuse
from the law enforcement that supposedly
are supposed to be working for Cindy
Bachman public information officer with
the San Bernardino County Sheriff's
Department it's my understanding that
the relationship with the with the local
law enforcement officers and the
community is very positive the Sheriff's
Department didn't provide numbers on
civilian complaints but it's striking
how many people in this community say
the relationship with the police had
deteriorated long before Allen Kephart's
death an unprecedented crackdown on
community that has been pretty sleepy
and easygoing and now if you don't put
your blinker on you're done I used to
know every deputy up here I knew every
captain that was ever up here up until
the last two captains the last two
captains they don't seem to be forward
with the community they got a job to do
I understand that I think that there's a
lot of stuff that that's gonna have to
change it's going to have to change from
the law enforcement field the residents
we spoke with were unanimous in saying
what a gentle caring harmless person
Ellen Kephart was Allen was the good boy
he never got into trouble he didn't run
around with the other rough boys he he
was just a good kid he's never
approached anybody to hurt anybody he
would always save everybody he was very
well thought of highly by a lot of
people he had a good heart never like my
husband said never saw him in 43 years
raised his fist to anybody here
anything like that after the service
we're gonna have some refreshments and
then whoever wants to go on a walk with
us and we're gonna leave from the
cottage restaurant in room forest and
walked to Valero gas station in honor of
Ellen today
[Music]
it's gonna take a lot of a lot of time
because this isn't something just goes
away I mean every time I Drive down the
road past that gas station every time I
see a law enforcement vehicle I you know
it son instantly
[Music]